nowhere else in the world outside of the
film industry will somebody try to
convince you that the thing that you
want is not actually what you want
james off camera you mentioned an
interesting analogy based on a
conversation with your friend about
distribution yeah so distribution and
also like what audience's expectations
are so um you know there's there's a
couple things that i would talk about
within that but like you know for for
instance like i know for me i have a
responsibility when i'm making a movie
for for an audience is like you know
when i make that movie there's they're
spending that same 7.99 whether it's you
know my movie or a studio movie to rent
it right or to buy it or whatever 4.99
whatever it is it's the same amount of
money so i have i have a responsibility
to the audience to over deliver with
beyond my budget as well as like give
them
what they're expecting of a movie like
this so like if i you know if they if
they if they're ordering this movie and
this movie is a turkey sandwich i can't
come out and then say okay well i know
you were expecting a turkey sandwich but
let me give you some lasagna like you
don't order that at a restaurant and
somebody comes out with like lasagna and
goes well i think you like lasagna more
that doesn't work that way so the way i
think of it also is like you know when
i'm talking to distributors distributors
are expecting a certain thing so when
you explain to them the movie you know
they want to know what comes in it so
you could explain what's inside the
turkey sandwich but you can't say guys
guys guys i know you want a turkey
sandwich but why don't we get some pizza
like it's just that if they want a
specific thing that's what they want and
so it's it's you got to find how to be
creative within making that thing versus
trying to convince them that they're
actually hungry for something completely
different and so that i i like to relate
things back to food because food is a
universal language in the sense that
everybody no matter how much they know
about movie they know enough about food
right and when you think about food in
that sense
it it takes the ego out of it because
it's not like you know it's not like you
going like oh well you know my personal
dreams and goals for this sandwich or
this you start going okay well i could
add this to it i could add this to it i
could add this to it it takes the ego
out right so i think a lot of that is is
you've got to take the ego out and look
at it as like you know
film is where
you know creativity
meets commerce like business meets
commerce so you can't forget about the
business side of things so business is
expecting to have things that hit
certain beats have a certain amount of
action have a certain amount of cast
yada yada yada so you have to fit within
those confines and i think if you think
of it outside of the box instead of like
well my dream and my creativity and my
this is one way and you think of it
outside of that
there's the movie that you're pitching
to the people that are financing and
buying the movie and then
the conversation you're having with the
actors or well my dream my this my that
dp is well my dream like this that's
good keep that in there but when it's
two different conversations you need to
be having if that makes sense so i think
if you are outside of yourself and look
at it in in as a concept of food it all
kind of makes more sense and it sounds
like sillier to you if you're like oh
well they ordered a turkey sandwich but
i want to give them like you know
spaghetti and meatballs you know but if
if if you are able to understand the
standpoint of you know the financier of
the distributor if this is what they
expect then you can be creative within
that world i think that's a fun analogy
i like that did you ever try to
offer you know spaghetti bolognese to a
distributor and they wanted
you know the cobb salad and so you
learned that the hard way i feel like
every single every single
thing that i have learned is from some
type of trial and error where like i you
know i i went in there and i was like
you know i remember i was pitching you
know unnamed distributor a movie and
they'd done like a bunch of action
movies and stuff like that and i was
like listen this thing we could possibly
submit it to sundance like
they were looking for something that
would go into redbox like you know you
don't go in there going like guys this
is going to be a sundance darling to a
company that does movies that they want
for redbox and netflix you know you've
got to understand who who the buyer is
and and what their order is
there you go right right it's like their
order for one of these food deliveries
exactly and so if you're changing it on
the phone yeah yeah it's like you know
imagine imagine just this conversation
like you call me right now and you say
like james i want to order like you know
try ordering i don't know like some
pizza sure okay so um hey is this um
james james delivery yeah yeah yeah this
is james delivery oh yeah hey uh yeah so
i think i'll have the um do you guys
have the
turkey on do you have gluten-free right
so i interestingly enough i really think
you should have some sushi
okay we've never made sushi before don't
get me wrong but i think this sushi
would be really tasty
okay well i was actually more hoping for
like turkey with um gluten-free bread
meat i know i told you i make turkey
sandwiches and this is a turkey sandwich
business but we're making sushi today so
sushi is what you should have you see
like if you if you get out of that whole
like mindset you're like this is a
ridiculous conversation nowhere else in
the world outside of the film industry
will somebody try to convince you that
the thing that you want is not actually
what you want sure so i think that once
you once people start to think like that
like you know it's business to the
distributors yes they love the creative
side but it's business to them it's
business to the producers so when you
start to think in the business
standpoint they want the thing that
they're buying
interesting yeah that's that's a fun way
to present it because it does make sense
if you're calling up with one order and
someone's trying to convince you of a
completely different thing yeah it
doesn't make any sense yeah exactly it
makes no sense it's almost insulting
it's like why is this person trying to
convince me to get something else like
what if they're vegan like
well like they don't they don't eat that
so you know so so i think find a way to
be creative within
what the person wants versus trying to
convince them they want something
completely different
right and what if you're
you're realizing that they want to stick
with a certain food group for lack of a
better term but
they want it very limiting and you want
to add things to this thing so they want
a turkey sandwich but they want a very
bland but you want to
maybe have focaccia bread and you want
lettuce and
you want to spice it up so the weirdest
thing that you'll experience is most of
them don't care if you spice it up
they're okay with that they're like oh
yeah they like the idea of oh you want
to do this you want to add more you want
to add more turkey you want to add more
action you know you want to add a little
bit more action to this great you want
to you want to throw in like a little
bit more uh you know of a character arc
you're great you know a little bit of
mustard great like you know they're cool
with that um they just don't want you to
just
go so far that suddenly it's a salad
i see
you know so you have to you have to know
what the limits and borders are of that
right and is there a time and a place to
present
your ideas or all that should be done in
the preliminary
meetings with the distributor
the distributors mostly want to
understand the basic concept of the
movie they want to understand like okay
this is um you know
an action movie where guys rescuing this
person from a burning building and blah
blah they want to understand that right
uh they want to understand how often
action happens what are the big set
pieces like you know there's this the
fight that happens on a jet ski great
they want to know all these different
things right but they don't
uh they don't necessarily i mean they
they do want to read the script and know
that it's a good script
um but when you're pitching them
initially i don't think you need to get
as far into
uh all that other stuff i think what you
can do is once they're interested and
they're hooked and you're going back and
forth is you could go like hey i think
this would be much better if we do this
and like that could that could help for
sure but i think you know
it's it's it's better to kind of you
know expand as the movie expands
do you ever have a distributor change it
on you where they say i know we said x y
and z but we're actually going a
different direction no i've never had
that you've never had that happen okay
no no i've never had that happen you
make it sound like you're in talks with
distributors before you make the movie
yeah a lot of the time a lot of the time
not always because i'm i'm sometimes i'm
work for hire so i'm hired as the
director and so maybe the producer
wasn't in talks or whatever i might not
be in those conversations but a lot of
the time where i'm producing and
directing or i'm you know just producing
i'm i'm i'm talking with the distributor
uh because a lot of the time you know in
this world you want to know that the
distributor
uh
would be interested in a movie like this
with a certain type of cast or this
before the movie's ever made
so that's
best to have those conversations and to
find i don't know i don't necessarily
know if it's best i i just know that
it's less risky
ah because you could make an incredible
film then it turns out you could always
yeah you could you could make an
incredible film that hits all the beats
and a distributor would pay way more for
it when it's done right but you could
also
make an incredible film that doesn't hit
the beats and the distributor would pay
less way less for it when it's done
than if they didn't if they hadn't been
made aware of it prior if that makes
sense